foreign
site blocked I'm a seventh grader living
in China
far away from my home country but it's
okay because I have great friends at
school
every day when I return to our apartment
I get on Facebook
yeah I lied about my age so I could
create an account but so did all my
friends so I have no regrets
I get on Facebook
and chat with my friends writing jokes
on their walls complaining about
homework
because what else is there to do for a
lonely 12 year old other than to get on
Facebook
until one day my computer gives me this
message
error site blocked
I refresh the page
same message
refresh again
same message one more time
air site blocked
I feel confused
I feel frustrated
I feel angry
what am I supposed to do now
in the next couple of days I find out
that the Chinese government has started
cracking down on Western social media
because it was used to organize
anti-government rights
now I'm even more confused
isn't Facebook supposed to be a place to
hang out with your friends
why does the government feel threatened
shouldn't Facebook be a place where
people can chat freely in a safe
environment
fast forward a dozen years now my
computer gives me this message
we're coming for your head
stop censoring us
you'll soon be in federal prison for
your communist crimes
by now I work at Facebook
it's not supposed to be funny but
um
I'm an engineer on the Integrity team my
job is to create a space a place where
people can chat freely in a safe
environment
along with those threats I receive a
call from this Facebook security team
they informed me that documents had been
leaked documents that named me and my
work on moderating anti-vaccine comments
at the height of the pandemic
the week was by project Veritas a
right-wing activist group that had
targeted Planned Parenthood and PR CNN
and the Washington Post
I'm assigned a security detail around
the clock and another team starts a
thorough online risk assessment to make
sure that sensitive information about me
is not available online
I feel confused
I feel scared
I feel angry
for the next couple of weeks I try to
stay indoors as much as possible the few
times I do go out I find myself looking
around
wondering if they finally discovered
where I live
A co-worker of mine is even confronted
picking his picking his son up from his
tennis lesson
I've been working hard at making the
platform a safer space
but now I know it is far from safe
criticism didn't just come from Project
Veritas and Sean Hannity it came from a
former co-worker through the Wall Street
Journal Facebook papers
she condemned Facebook for its lack of
action on coven misinformation
President Biden stated that platforms
like Facebook were killing people for
not doing enough to moderate
inflammatory content
we were criticized for not censoring
enough
and censoring too much
so what is the right balance between
complete freedom of speech and extreme
content moderation
as a former Insider at Facebook
I want to share my proposals for what
social media platforms ought to do
we need content moderation on social
media platforms to protect freedom of
speech and provide users with a safe
environment
a platform that amplifies hate speech
harassment and misinformation is not a
safe space for people to speak up
despite what Elon Musk May tweet
but you might be wondering
isn't content moderation just another
way to say censorship
how can the infringement of Freedom
protect freedom
okay
imagine you're behind the wheel drive
it can get frustrating at times when you
run into a red light for the third time
in a row
maybe you wish traffic lights didn't
exist
how dare a random color light tell me
what I can and cannot do
but imagine a world without traffic laws
how dangerous would that be
traffic lights May restrict your freedom
to speed through intersections anytime
you want
But ultimately
they let you drive more freely
content moderation and platform policies
are the traffic laws of the online space
so how should the traffic be directed
first
platforms should use experts
in human rights Public Safety and law to
craft clear and transparent policies
about what does not belong on the
platform things like hate speech
harassment and misinformation
then these policies should be shared
publicly
and revised as needed based on user
feedback
second
platforms should use appropriate
treatments to carry out these policies
what are these appropriate treatments
when the severity of harm is low and the
detection Precision is low
content should be selected for manual
review
to continue with the traffic analogy
this would be like getting pulled over
when the severity of harm is high and
the detection Precision is high
content should be automatically removed
from the platform
you may remember seeing a warning screen
pop up on on Instagram when you try to
share certain claims about election
results
that's called reshare friction which
aims to slow you down from thoughtlessly
sharing harmful content
just like a speed bump
warning screens on covid misinformation
posts directed users to trustworthy
Health Resources like the CDC website a
traffic sign if you will
another powerful treatment is debusting
the secret sauce of social media is its
algorithm that recommends you posts that
will maximize engagement
unfortunately
inflammatory posts are inclined to be
boosted because they tend to collect a
lot of reactions and comments
debusting is a way to prevent these
posts from being recommended
platforms should use a combination of
manual review automatic removal
reshare fiction warning screens and
debusting to minimize toxic experiences
for their users
but I have to admit content moderation
is a whack-a-mole approach to reducing
harm it will always be a step behind
as long as platforms prioritize
engagement and then try to remove toxic
experiences users will continue to be
exposed to some degree of toxic content
so how can platforms go beyond
minimizing harm to maximizing benefit
here are my suggestions
first
platforms should listen to users and
serve them what they value
in order to do so they must give users
explicit controls so that they can voice
their preferences
things like show more or show lets
buttons on posts are great ways to
identify what users actually value and
topics they do not want to see
second
platforms should actively boost content
that brings people together to promote
civil conversations
at Facebook we found that when positive
reactions like love and like come from a
diverse group of users the content is
perceived to be insightful and civil
both by the participants and Observers
by boosting this type of content
platforms can create Harmony even on
divisive topics and incentivize users to
act better
imagine a social media platform where
teenagers can hang out with their
friends after school instead of feeling
lonely
imagine a social media platform where
people can chat freely in a safe
environment
in the long history of communication
social media is still at its infancy
if platforms don't change however we
will continue to see our society become
even more divided than ever
I refuse to believe that this is the
best version of social media
I know we can make it better
so what can you do
support platforms that put user safety
first
and actively promote civil conversations
instead of feeling confused
frustrated
and angry
I feel joyful
I feel excited
I feel optimistic thank you everyone
[Music]